I just have some questions as far as
John if he doesn't get the takedown
what's it look like not saying he can't
just get some questions he's still the
goat but I do got some questions we
didn't learn anything that night we
learned that he can still wrestle I
think Sarah God is not you know is no
background no jiu jitsu so yeah John
like phenomenal easiest fight of his
career hands down easiest fight he's
ever had a guy that has literally zero
wrestling doesn't trade in the offseason
easiest fight of his career I do think
steepe is going to be more of a threat
and a very steep it can wrestle
Cleveland State wrestled in college so
because also for John three year layoff
this and there's no warm-up fights in
the UFC but this was a warm-up fight for
him even though it was for a world title
this a guy who can't wrestle in any
capacity this was a warm-up fight so the
steebay fight I think we're gonna find
out a lot more about where Jon Jones is
at at a heavyweight than we did in the
cereal God play